[Musique]
oh
on va
m
oui moi
et toi
pour m
ah ah
[Musique]
et ouais si l'une est trop sport nuit
bleue l'émission qui te venge des autres
c'est bien au chaud l'artichaut
bye bye camarades d'allemagne de l'est
avant les autres elle a fait le mur
l'enfance boy scout scoop et les délires
de nina hagen et éthiques lunettes c'est
prendre des risques pour les premiers
disques brisseau nuke pas mal du tout
blind test corti dj didier barbelivien
ne connaît-il que ces deux mille
chansons j'en ai peur aux offres on
adule on brûle les expos d'art du trash
baby james et ses fameux trois jeunes
dames c'est une allure elle s'est fait
refaire le nez elle a des soutiens gorge
gros bonnets les souvent d'infos au ciné
qui ces interviews mystère tradition
beriou lindbergh saint-ex du baron rouge
et du baron noir à toute berzingue dans
les avions star sixty du ciné spaghetti
de fellini à pasolini laon l'appétit
confie le meilleur des meilleurs ce soir
flower power sa place au prize il y
avait une française parmi les superstars
de warhol elle est là elle raconte
mettons les jumeaux de lamotte ont alvin
et calvin exclu lui merci thierry le
rock indé s'est plaint d'idc indies man
with pas d'erreur on adore delphine tort
arroyo ex beau show presque royco wacey
lunettes noires pour nuit blanche le
magazine du samedi soir bonsoir on
commence avec barbelivien didier le
meilleur songwriter français est aussi
il faut bien le dire le plus mauvais au
blind test alors didier barbelivien on
t'appelle monsieur tube ouais ça l'a
écrit combien à peu près dans la presse
ça arrive non c'est pas ce que c'est que
de faire un tube ce serait trop facile
parce que j'ai dû écrire 2000 chansons
dans ma vie et et on a 30 qu'on connaît
vraiment en quoi un tel cas elle
m'oublie pour johnny c'est bien ça ouais
il ya dix ans elle mobilise une nouvelle
chanson c'est vrai qu'il a fait en dix
minutes celle-là 25 minutes 25 minutes
tu penses quoi tu qu'il a fait johnny
hallyday croda gillet et david l'avenir
a devancé un bel album non additionne
tout le monde maintenant je dit pas du
bien tout le monde mais c'est d'abord
moi j'adore johnny hallyday j'avais
encore des gilles tu me fera pas dire du
mal ni de l'un ni de l'autre et je
trouve que c'est un beau 10 quoi par
contre un truc de toi qui est absolument
insupportable en ce moment tu le sais
c'est je te survivrai non moi je trouve
pas non c'est ton client maintenant s'il
voit c'est pas mon client non non c'est
pas pour ça que je dis ça et julien
clerc et a déçu tu dis par rapport à ce
qu'il faisait au début avec maurice
vallet avec roda gil tu dis
qu'aujourd'hui quand on entend la fille
aux bas nylon c'est pas comme qu'on
entende la cavalerie ouais t'as vu ça
mais parce que je suis né un immense fan
de julien clerc c'est pour ça sur moi
j'ai tellement aimé
ivanovic ou les fleurs des gares où la
petite sorcière malades ou yann et les
dauphins que je trouve que ça s'est un
peu banalisé dans les mots quoi encore
que bon il est fait des trucs avec
d'abedi qui était très très beau mais
moi j'étais un grand fan de la
combinaison maurice vallet et roda gil
il trouve qu'il devrait revenir à cette
combinaison bon bah ouais moi je serais
lui je l'aurais jamais quitté même je
veux dire moi si j'avais eu en tant
qu'interprète des auteurs comme etienne
et maurice quoi je continuerai de
chanter leurs textes sur les lalanne pas
trop non plus hein tu as dit que c'était
un apprenti léo ferré ouais ouais t'es
bien renseigné j'ai dit ça à lourdes
dans télé 7 jours mais c'était un peu
pour lui mais après j'ai
rencontré le type il est plutôt simple à
francis lalanne mai mais tous côtés tu
fais gaffe il frappe en plus ouais bah
ouais ouais il a frappé par il attrapé
un mag il s'est pas défendu mais alors
est-ce que c'est à force de te moulé
comme salon d imaginaire celui de jean
pierre françois que tu as décidé de
faire une carrière solo parce que ton
pouvait plus parce que tu viens seul
coup tu non pas du tout c'est marrant
que j'aime bien je cherche pas vraiment
à faire une carrière solo mais j'aime
bien enregistrer des disques j'en
enregistre depuis 15 ans maintenant un
peu plus de 15 ans j'aime bien ça la
fait quelques bidons les 70 puis ça a
commencé à marcher avec elle elle de 800
mille huit cent mille disques mais je
l'ait pas fait exprès donc lui puisque
le celui d'après j'en ai vendu 38 cela
ça veut rien dire et paie pour le light
est prêt c'est beaucoup dire mais en
face on fait le subir qua non jean
pierre françois je peux surfer
[Musique]
je sais pas les stones la jav in spain
on a les nightmare des crimes va tous
nous les faire ces douze jeunes que ça
captain beefheart n'a beaucoup de jeunes
c'est des petits je sais pas je connais
pas ce petit peu pas l'entendre rapporte
apa la pochette non jeudi
initiale
dans le lait ou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça soulage ouais abstral quatre
annonceurs
[Musique]
audible
je n'ai jamais vu un cas rien trouvé à
la mémoire je suis sûr que j'ai rien
trouvé grâce à un exploit en quelque
sorte
[Musique]
sa leçon mais oui le grand groupe bab et
thuc est toujours là les sépales pink
floyd ouais
[Applaudissements]
bah voila si vous m'aidez comme ça je
vais pas finir nul il faut l'aider mais
dévoile a voulu montrer les pochettes
[Musique]
smaghi cède en ce jeu
là l'effet de sa qualité quoi
je souhaite à internet en
[Applaudissements]
les mines et une série télé gallas et
vous les télés ouais ouais comme lancel
ou aïd à luri dois je connais c'est un
truc de lou reed the wall
suivant
sa scénique ouais ouais je
[Applaudissements]
sais pas si je peux comme goris que les
gogos fin d'année c'est ce que j'aime
vraiment ça ouais ça c'est vraiment
génial ah ouais rafter match mais on me
down accordé
on continue non et cela laisse l'algérie
par vasilopoulos moi la question
produits sont les champions sur le plus
de plaisir en posant les questions
depuis début mai la vase qui sait ça
mick jagger leur logis bravo
ça fait 3 c j'ai trouvé ici des floyd
ouais les rolling stones mick jagger des
rolling stones tu veux pas me reposer la
question de ce qui c'est c'est les
stones scénique jegham aura beau jeu
suivant
la
cimade non non non non non ça c'est
tellement facile de voir remonter son or
si mes impôts leçon j'entends pas si ça
garçons ou filles
as un garçon c'est qui ces scènes
chaussures que nous mais j'écoute ça
toute la journée à la radio mais je
retiens parlez-vous d'ananas
ici je pense pas pas quand je fais
[Applaudissements]
le
magasin si je connaissais qui s'éteint
[Musique]
c'est
là aussi c'est connu structure si c'est
moi je danse dessus
devant lui oui
vous avez bien sûr c'est china girl non
non c'est l'autre
acheteur c'est quoi hb je réussis ashes
to ashes exactement
[Musique]
danone
non non je connais que ça mais les noms
soient dirigés d'une longue tu sais pas
non l'énoncé seul
à temps si ça les colts étaient forts ah
non nul à rennes alors le roi qui
heureusement avec les gens c'est le roi
qui est mort à banon je sais pas mais si
celui qui croit que tout cas c'est tout
henri iv au rite bon alors
si c'est bien on attend ses grandeurs
washington on every day the book wemmel
titre là c'est à temps
c'est le pire que j'aie vu des évêques
et cissé washington chinois mais si
mais si c'est lui enfin
là on n'en attend pas pour les charrois
qu'on s'en prenant aux attentes
j'ai acheté les caissettes en plus c'est
insensé concentre-toi est moderne
s'agissait pour lui mais non c'est
non j'ai pas le droit de crier comme ça
quand je crie mme pitre quand même je
sais pas c'est lui ce que celle aux
habitants aux évidemment mais en plus
j'ai pris que les tubes à
ses demandes
[Musique]
et
m
james taylor
c'est comme si moi j'ai essayer d'égaler
chanson là non d'abaisser ses
redoutables votre fait par la pochette
on a au début
bon tu sais pas c'est julian lennon
ouais je ne peux rien moi c'est pareil
j'ai reconnu par tous la paix mais on
entend mal ces médias nationaux
du match
aller 3 1
la bande des quatre
[Musique]
la marlène duras dafang célina after
pong bresse glazik avec olmi ambiance
mahalia jackson n'est ce pas que ça
sonne après quatre ans d'absence qu'est
ce que tu en penses
[Musique]
mais
mais oh
yma lee
migaud
et pour m
m oui
oh
non
[Musique]
nicolau
à
oui
[Musique]
et
à
au palace la berliner fait un malheur
come back après un voyage sans retour
nous
oui
ni bacchanales ni lacrymal mais
primordiale ils étaient tous au mémorial
de christian lebrun le vendredi 22
septembre à ris orangis pour mémoire les
lunettes noires d'elena à la guitare
philippe dauga
ouais
elliott murphy
les innocents
les ablettes
tulipes logan
les garçons bouchers
mais
[Musique]
blum de beast le magazine que christian
dirigé youri lenquette
aubert
[Musique]
axel bauer
christine lidon
[Musique]
les ducks
et le bob story
et gamines voilà les halles je salue
question
comme prévu la gaine isiro guen
nina
wang
are you do you think you are the only
jupp heynckes tarceva
[Applaudissements]
à 2 500
da
you fuck you by the new dance joplin
sociaux pour 200 enfin une violence
sixties qui nous a nommé 10h10
following
syngenta pline james brown chinatown à
la salle bondeaux link ferries strauss
kahn idiot ce point
[Musique]
là bas tu
ne rates and other
people en continu
nicolaï gedda
économie empty
des animaux y compris like reason of
new
economy lakers
ou la
folie des
bilans
[Musique]
non food point d'orgue du temps
voilà
l'accord de la
france
avant cela
photo aw
crédibilité
at on pu lire
des livres yucel walywood planète
quand 500 titres air field est présente
au
resto est une oeuvre humaine
la fin avant que vous avez béziade vote
pour nous parents ces derniers
vous la bourrine son envoi tout ça use
ça use
in en
[Musique]
suspens mystère d'abord interview
blister 7k nationalité
oh
tu es né ou en profondeur c'est pour ça
que son vrai prénom c'est mérienne
non on recommence et n'a même pas ce que
c'était ma grand mère s'appelait comme
ça et ce qu'elle est et nasri du nord
mais elle ne restait que 1 en quoi donc
c'est un muscle du prénom ça j'aime
beaucoup et je m'en vais garder sa fin
rapporte rencontrera est ce que tu te
trouves belle comme qui
s'affairent à tanger faire ça on aime
toi
j'ai pas dit beaucoup
avancé pour dire que quand on a envie de
faire pour le faire quoi ouais donc non
je n'en ai fusionnant les défis
tellement fidèle couach a tout entendu
sur ok tu fais combien de tour de
poitrine 37,2 ou 95 cette
raison qu'à 37 des îles de faire
référencer et 84 95 des bonnets des
points communs car ils vont trouver
quand même je venais des visas pour les
copines j'ai kiffé pareil quoi ces bonus
mais à voir les bonnets avec le tour du
port ces femmes j'ai du tour étant de
corse et les chiffres et faits avait
cédé pied à travers du bonnet c est ce
qu'il ya eu dans les blés oui enfin vers
caen fait la fabrique et qui faisait
quoi ton papa comme métier il est il
écrit jean jaurès dans la presse la
télévision
le correspondant alors on était à quelle
classe j'ai été viré souvent si la
télévision est en fait tu vois ce qu'il
était
quelques mois qu'elle fait ça je suis
contente que tu en parles je vais parler
et en fait vous devriez rentrer à la
maison dès lundi soir dépité
complètement défait j'trouve ça métier
qui est monstrueuse tout mais encore
plus maintenant je crois qu'il faut
quelquefois depuis sept mois le mètre
quatre-vingt trois thèmes de manche vous
n'avez plus malhonnêtes qui réussissait
à télé du point comme je suis d'ailleurs
ce n'est pas du métier pouvoir disant
que oui l'appareil qui comprend les tirs
on t'apprend être honnête voilà on dit
en france 3 1 mais bonjour à croissance
rapide et meilleure audience quoi
ça a pris beaucoup de trucs à l'école
oui mais je me suis fait rien on va
prendre un mot simple par exemple au
nanisme est ce que ça veut dire on à
nice
tu as fait d'armé
bon c'est pat était favorable au jeu
d'iroquois pas
est ce que tu as fait l'armée
c'est une vraie fille
ça va aider les téléspectateurs à savoir
qui tu es amené du tabac alcool drogue
sûrement pas quoi
quelqu'un qui a récemment indiqué à la
cocaïne à la tv quand je trouve que
c'est pas bien qu'elle l'ait dit ah bon
parce que je suis un enfant a besoin de
françoise sagan j'aime beaucoup beaucoup
d'ailleurs je trouve une femme qui a
beaucoup de classe et ce qu'il fallait
dire sa petite fille qui sont là qui
regarde une camera 3 face à salles sur
un bond est donc venu envers l'alcool
quelquefois bah oui c'est par des coups
d'éclat titulaire peut tu vois sauver
comme ça vers 7 heures du matin quand tu
dis j'aime tous les excès oui c'est quoi
alors les excès si c'était si tu
rencontres est encore là les
techniques en vigueur avec les eft je te
donne envie de faire mais l'excès paye
ton premier flirt à quel âge
tu crois qu'il s'en souvient
et ton premier amour
c'est
tout ça pour ça dis donc
pourquoi tu joues toujours des rôles de
l'info français dernier palenfo et
espérer qu'un pâle chose et puis dans et
puis dans la femme est folle et bah oui
c'est marrant mais j'ai fait que deux
fois dont j'ai fait d'autres os et
banquière secrète est élu par apple il
dépend des bons d'essence et fibre à tes
meilleurs tout cas j'étais pas du tout
puissant tir valette beau langage et la
pauvreté
après le conservatoire enfin après ton
échec le conservatoire tu aller
travailler aux standards de radio france
et c'est vrai qu'ils étaient jetés sur
les montants comme ça pour le brancher
pour faire une carrière qu'est ce qu'il
a fait pour toi lui demandant alors il
n'ya rien parce que j'ai mangé laisser
tomber parce que je sentais que je sais
pas ça n'allait pas avec eux j'ai senti
chez un homme habituellement les bleds
que pépé pour être direct est il voulait
me sauter
c'est ce que j'ai
réservé mon savon et ben je vais pas
tout à fait perdu j'ai pu en fait et si
on dit que tu as fait deux films avec
anglade tu crois que les gens dansent
avoir quitté
comment pourrait être reconnaître qu est
ce que tu pourrais dire ou faire qui
permettent de reconnaître
ben non mais pas sur la demande et 15,3
kg que des rôles de la fois mal alors
quand cet appareil c'est qu'un petit
voyage en effet qu'un seul réel mais
c'est à dire ce genre de questions tu le
penses sans toi mais non mais non
interview mystère solution après la
chanson
au fait les aiguilleurs du ciel ont
encore fait une belle les avions sont
dans les barrages pour tous ces visages
c'est comme
souffler
c'est clair
comme madame
bello
mais qui sait
c'est juste à revoir ce soir
painchaud
une cale
oh
[Musique]
c
tu
tu les verts déjà dû là oublié
en garde
commentait
louette
les civils
les blues ont
ajouté
m
c'est juste un
illusion
[Musique]
ajoie
une histoire
seulement
[Musique]
à
je
[Musique]
là
tu es
[Musique]
et
e
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'étaient les avions et leur nouvel
album loin normal on approche de la
vérité sur le mystère de l'inviter fine
un peu divine super coquine très maligne
c'est clémentine célarié à l'interview
promo elle a tout ce qu'il faut coco tu
sais pourquoi tu as fait la table au
ministère
pourquoi parce qu'on voit partout à la
télé lundi lundi dernier je vous ma télé
je trouverais sur l'a5 en train de faire
la cuisine mais samedi soir était sur
l'a2 on va le faire lunettes noires
at-il gagneuse non mais aussi à se faire
avorter à temps mais c'est parce que tu
sais c'est notre entreprise avec
christophe fraîcheur cela on a tous et
tous les deux on a fait une des sociétés
on n'est pas beaucoup d'argent parce que
l'on croit contenter de ses fonctions au
cap as a commencé au mois deux mois de
juillet non c'est ça et ça et ça
continue jusqu'en octobre tellement ça
marche oui ça s'appelle marcela seoudi
le large alors passer par sont en panne
ya un truc très important je suis pas
venu en voiture venir en métro alors
pour se garer c'est un bordel pas
possible là bas quercy rugby des hauts
donc c'est au coin de la place clichy
dos est lancé à 8h30 battu à dix et le
le rôle que le cinéma ne m'a jamais
offert ça veut dire que tu fais pendant
une heure et demie ce que tu faisais
pendant dix minutes et demie au cinéma
c'est ça oui enfin à 10 minutes ou même
cinq minutes qu'il faudrait environ 20
demandes par an tandis que ça y est
c'est fait fabre mais non monsieur
qu'est ce qui est heureusement qu'ils
n'ont pas faire ça parce qu'il pouvait
pas imaginer si tu veux parce que moi je
fais juste pour toi tu cries quand tu es
une femme là il faut pas crier pas
parler trop fort il faut dire que je
profite d'un personnage qu'on invente
avec christophe comme ça on se dit tiens
dedans on va mettre tous mes tours
durant points c'est une maîtresse
qu'elle apprenne fiancée mort plein
ouais m'enfin a qu'un pas je suis tout à
londres puisque ont saisi dans cette
veine en procès du coran pour faire ils
apprennent tous épuisés mans mais il est
mieux les maîtres quand même
gachet tradition c'est que elle et les
différences et ça quand même on voulait
vous le faire quelqu'un différent parce
que la différence des gens différents
qui s'offre quelques fois et alors
qu'ils devraient pour tout faire
elle est différente elle est heureux on
connaît les gens à l'aise presse donne
du bonheur oui j'ai ça et laissait y
voient la fin des classes mais oui je
m'amuse bien mûri je vis bien c'est ce
que tu veux maintenant j'en redemande
quelquefois des trucs au genre mais je
les bras quand il faut pas trop croire
la la j'ai participé je pense parce
qu'il fait on pas dit que je crois ça
met gentiment tu vois on fait des
bêtises alors j'en demande pour des
gorilles quand on aime on fait comme si
on était au cinéma puisque grégory dans
la jungle avec ce qu'ils attrapent une
banane c'est dans le danseur oui la lune
et ravalomanana fait pas de banane c'est
safina pictures et qu'on fait rêver mais
en fait ils font quand même les goristes
qui font la mer quand j'ai que c'est la
mère et où il participe l'heure des
centaines de steve et ils le font avec
eux enfin comme ça c'est assez génial
venu samedi surtout sur ce qu'ils font
restons dignes voici aux neuf cette
semaine spéciale fiac lunettes catalogue
l'art une belle galerie baudoin lebon 34
des archives jusqu'au 7 octobre
rétrospective 70 90 alfred courmas
beaubourg jusqu'au 28 octobre par
pionnier du peuple l'un des premiers à
avoir synthétisé populisme et onirisme
la preuve il a 90 ans mario mertz
galerie améliorera chaud jusqu'à fin
octobre la rétrospective c'est au bugue
et naïve homme louis de grandmaison
galerie pierre lescot jusqu'au 14
octobre fidèles à l'abstraction ça tombe
bien on y revient
-on andy warhol jean-michel basquiat
avenue matignon dans sa nouvelle galerie
qui dit un verre présente jusqu'au 25
novembre leur collaboration qui a fait
quoi ils sont morts tous les deux ans 87
à 6 mois l'écart l'étoile reste et le
livre d'isabelle dufresne dans quelques
minutes sur lunettes banane d'or
à mort les galeries durant dessert à
l'endroit ou à l'envers aucun problème
ça revient au même tatane de la semaine
off chéri samba le style actuel c'est
dépassé lui mais tu n'as pas attraper la
coqueluche de la rentrée
[Musique]
voyez vous mesdames messieurs le gimmick
c'est qu'elle est atomique la presse
britannique s'interroge sur l'intellect
de vendée nous on dit pour être si
blonde ou est brillante c'est exclu lui
c'est exquis ces bandits
c'est fait
le chalut
[Musique]
non
je suis
[Musique]
m
elle
[Musique]
m
je vais
[Musique]
ce sujet
à
c'était transvision van t'land ce live
la bande-annonce d'amour vertige au
palace le 7 octobre est maintenant grand
moment là aura betty parle de sa vie
moravia alberto fellini federico
pasolini pierpaolo cinecittà et via
veneto laura betti alors laura betti
bonsoir c'est vrai que ton vrai nom
c'est toujours baty on voit ça si tu
commences par là là je m'arrête
[Musique]
oh
pourquoi est-ce que c'est pas joli ça
pas ce soir président bête c'est la
3c visconti qui a changé c'est vrai ça
c'est vrai côté actrices fétiches du
cinéma italien des années 60 c'est ta
définition dans le dictionnaire
la bonne qui monte au ciel dans théorème
la la surf ou et art de alan enfants
c'est comme ça qu'on te raconte en
général la regina de 1900 ça va comme ça
où ça va tu tu achètes très bien mais
lorsqu'on sait pas par contre c'est
qu'avant tout ça j'avais fait une
apparition à paris en 1961 62 savais pas
du tout formidable et tu chanter sur
scène c'était à l'athénée non alors j'ai
chanté d'abord à l'athénée puis ensuite
à la comédie de paris toujours le même
aller et puis à la tête de l'art alors
là c'était du plomb héroïsme parce que
je suis arrivé avec mon tour de chant
qui s'appelait tour à vide en plein
c'était le moment de l' os c'était très
sympa 60 et 61 62 passa bien alors
un spectacle oui à peu près mekhadma ua
au sujet du soir wen dans la halle si je
n'écoutais pas bien sûr alors un soir
par exemple à kobe paris il y avait
quelqu'un qui me gêne et terriblement
parce qu il riait d'une façon je ne
comprenais pas terry est eric alors
j'appelle les directeurs et écouter se
moque de moi cela me coûte et ça fait la
troisième fois qu'il vient c'est un très
très bon
sur cela il avait même du papier
adorable car on s'est vus d'arqana
rajaouis qui avait des chansons de
moravia twente est allé voir me ravit en
lui demandant de tenir des chansons
ouais bon c'est la vie que c'est pour un
gars qui peut appliquer d'alors ouest
est passée dans la rue où il fait
comme ça parce qu il est il est toujours
très curieux alors moi je ne sais pas ce
que j'avais peut-être c'est parce que
j'arrivais de bologne mais il devait
trouver un peu insolite à rome mais
c'est vrai qu'en 59 tu avais déjà les
cuissardes noires ou oui c'est peut-être
pour s'acquitter ardoise oui je sais
ça fait travailler avec les limites tête
à jouer dans la dolce vita oui j'étais
la dernière cène à qui a une histoire
alors dans cette histoire marquée l'eau
pétillante et salle kaunas je lie aux
insultes alors cette scène devient
dati n'est qu'on avait fait on est allé
trouver fellini alors là dîné ensemble
il y avait alloué mai
gap a relevé -
pas de ligne et moi est fini et mike
bryan je ne sais pas ce qui s'est passé
à certains moments j'ai commencé à
insulter par qu'elle l'a quand même
meilleur ami mais insulter d'une
bannière encensé féline et là des très
bien très bien je sais ce que je vais
tourner il m'a donné le rôle taylor un
jour tu rencontres pasolini comment ça
s'est passé et moi et m'a fait tout de
suite je ris parce qu'il était tellement
sûr il y avait tellement sérieux il me
regardait avec des yeux éberlués là
comme si j'étais je ne sais pas quoi
m'a fait tout si triables voilà tu
voulais l'épouser quand tu l'a rencontré
et bae
oui oui j'étais amoureux quelques fous
l'camp maintenant coup de foudre alors
j'ai eu avec lui en dehors de la
relation professionnelle une relation
amoureuse certes nous habitions ensemble
d'après midi l'un des deux appartements
l'après-midi d'aller voir sa mère et
qu'il soit une victoire on avait des
habitudes des joueurs a été
hier soir il arrive est il arrivé est
moi je préparais l'accusé soit à manger
soit ressortait soit celui en vacances
ensemble si oui aussi mais comment
comment ça se passe et où ils étaient
homosexuels comment ça se passe et pour
toi la relation amoureuse avec lui n'est
pas un rapport d'amour main dans
l'essence traditionnelle
c'est vrai que quand je le rencontrais
moi je pense que il y a eu un coup de
foudre puis peu à peu on était venu à
grand ami couple mais avant c'est vrai
j'aurais aimé avoir des enfants avec be
par exemple
mais qui me posent des questions que le
oui à certains moments je pensais que
j'aurais dû
l'aider à avoir un enfant avec moi
mais
il ya des choses qui sont beaucoup plus
forts que nous voilà et quand il a
rencontré ninette haute a réagi comment
toi
très bien et à certains moments à
cette époque là
j'avais un autre 10 nitoo moi
personnellement j'ai
donc alors à certains moments on se
rende compte
qu'on avait une famille et chacun
enfants mais c'est vrai voilà c'est
d'abord crevé
c'était très beau
c'était jalouse quand même quand il
offrait des fleurs à maria callas quand
il a fait mais des aménagements pour
affûter jalousement huawei parce que j'y
voyais pas clair ouais je voyais pas
claire parce qu'il n'ya pas mille aimait
beaucoup les d'éléments et voilà disons
le franchement
oui il était un peu comme ça
on dit comme en france et a allumé la
lumière
alors franchement là alors on oublie une
chose
toi qui as dit pourquoi tu ne demande
pas pourquoi j'ai les lunettes noires
parce que tu es dans une émission qui
s'appelle lunettes noires comme tu es
très bien élevés tu mets des lunettes
noires voilà elle est où la caméra j'y
vois rien dans ma part si j'attrape et
caméras j'élève j'enlève j'irai partout
du capital et là c'est la laine ne l'a
jamais varlet jannez à deux voies alors
un jour tu as eu envie de faire un livre
et pier paolo pasolini tata dit écoute
tu vas signer un contrat tu vas toucher
une avance parce que tu es tellement
bourgeoise au fond que à partir du
moment où tu auras signé un contrat jeu
sera obligé de l'écrire et ce livre est
sorti en italie il ya cinq ans à peu
près il s'appelle en italie en tête avec
l'état mais ça veut dire quoi l'italien
tête avaient laine et tavel et à settat
a annonc e parle quand il avait 4 ans
si c'est qu'on cherche les mots à quand
les petits gourmands alors ils avaient
sentiment d'amour et savait pas comment
comment à l'exprimer alors il avait
avorté ces petits mots et avait donc à
fellini sort aujourd'hui en france chez
plon ça s'appelle madame tu racontes
fois dans ce livre
bah je raconte
l'histoire d'une un révolté et c'est à
cause de ça peut il y a aussi une
recherche sur la langue et sept langues
parlent
à lagash très crue c'est vrai mais un
c'est vraiment une révolte et de la
naissance c'est quelqu'un qui ne
l'accepté rien et ça c'est l'enfance
puis c'est une femme qui qui pourrait
être moi mais ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
dit ce n'est pas dit qui a subi un
trauma et
et qui suit tous les détails du drama et
puis d'un travail du deuil
donc pour moi le livre est très claire
sauf que ce personnage a à faire avec
une montre en main peut-être c'était
l'assassinât de pierre parle peut-être
si ses personnages c'est moi
[Musique]
exclu après les sisters après les
brothers la nouvelle mine c'est les
twins alvin et calvin la nouvelle fois
de moto mais candide et rigueur dit il
est parti
[Musique]
justice
ça nous sommes dues
[Musique]
non non non
com
le fort saint père
m
qu'est ce que c'est
c'est une richesse
[Musique]
jean l'herm
étant
[Musique]
ça
il faut que cette union
les
[Musique]
oui
non
[Musique]
oh moi je tape à bbb
m
[Musique]
jusqu'à nice
et
de santé
essai
la justice française
là
les abonnés cette voie
assez assez c'était les à ces blacks 5
in situ ation aylwin et calvin et voici
la souris preuve la factory ultraviolets
devenu bcbg ysabelle dufresne extrême
des amis de warhol ned rocknroll
ysabelle dufresne bonsoir j'ai fait une
grande découverte en lisant ton livre
c'est que parmi les superstars qui
entoure et andy warhol et ab une
française et c'était toi
[Musique]
oh
alors au départ tu fais partie d'une
bonne bourgeoisie grenobloise quoi des
gens plutôt riche
il est quoi oh mon père était ingénieur
enfin ce qu'on peut appeler industrielle
et une enfance assez difficile malgré
tout c'est à dire la petite fille un peu
sauvage comme ça au milieu d'une famille
bourgeoise on était dans une sorte de
courant on peut dire non d'un couvent à
l'autre parce qu'on m'a jetée d'une
porte à l'autre et chaque fois je me
rebelle est davantage et évidemment ça
s'est mal terminée maison de correction
20 exercices et tu es d'exorciser jean
fournier on y viendra parce qu'à la fin
du vide une sorte d'exorcisme et tu
étais réellement exorciser ses rares
enfin exorciser avec leur propre terme
c'est à dire qu'on vous met de l'eau
bénite il ya une prière spéciale enfin
fait par un prêtre je sais pas comment
se passent les autres exercices en tout
cas ça n'a pas marché où j'ai prétendu
tessa les marchés par valère devoir
marcher pendant les la suite du bouquin
une première expérience sexuelle assez
c'est difficile parce c'était presque un
viol d'une certaine façon que tu
racontes sa dent dans le bouquin enfin
sexuellement ça ne va pas bloquer pour
la suite non peut-être débloquer cette
intro débloquer peut-être on peut le
dire mais ce n'est pas cette a pas
réellement bloqués on sait aussi jamais
ce que ça fait de très difficile
d'établir les causes et les effets
peut-être que à ce moment là on perd 1
s'intéressent fait de la chose nous
allons tourbillon est très difficile de
savoir il faut que je crois 50 ans pour
les attirer les conclusions lors un jour
tes parents décident de t'envoyer ans
aux usa
ta soeur habite est en fait tu crois que
tu vas tu joues pas tu rangé des
voitures en arrivant là bas mais c'est
terrible ce qui arrive là bas tu n'as
qu'une envie c'est conquérir le monde de
l'art tu deviens un copines ou amis ou
amants avec des amis enfin un manque pas
vraiment parce qu'un jour tu es avec lui
voilà il caresse avec une langouste
what the hell cette femme est top
d'aline viennent de faire l'amour si
jamais allé plus loin non avec d'aline
celle-ci jamais de pénétration mais
plutôt d'imagination très vite dalit
présente à warhol qui à l'époque était
inconnu populaire
mais est tout de suite j'ai été fasciné
par le caractère parce que c'était un
homme vraiment une espèce d'extra
terrestres il ne parlait pas comme les
autres favoris par les appelle aussi
parler il avait lu une espèce de voix de
ventriloque et tout ce qu'il disait
était tellement à la fois génial ou
idiot tikva on ne savez jamais qui
s'était d'ailleurs de pâques boiral
c'est un paradoxe extraordinaire leur
première rencontre avec warhol tu lui
saute dessus tu es quand même un peu
enfin comme on dit vulgairement un peu
ce autographes quand même que le
souhaitez pour découvrir quel était cet
homme ou si vraiment c'était un homme
d'ailleurs l'expérience a été assez
facile des remparts ce sens que comme je
le raconte son corps et d'effroi
devenait de plus en plus glacial enfin
c'est juste un repas s'est libéré de toi
complètement et totalement failli quand
même il s'est d'abord refroidi
énormément j'ai cru qu'ils david tournay
à la glace il a perdu un peu zappé rue
il a plus ou moins épais de sa perruque
qui quand même resté accroché par un
bouton pression trop rester
un premier d'entre eux c'était quand
même pas un homme ordinaire
l'entente est devenu une superstar de la
fecq triste et qui les autres à l'époque
il est vivant il y avait jean fau s'il y
avait une grille de super stars qui
portent y avait brigitte bourjade folk
qui a pas trahi et interviews oui qui
était la fille de brigitte boyle de
monsieur berline qui était le président
de la société insiste y avait eu elles
allaient ils venaient mais aussi les
tables principal qui avait quelques
heures aussi toi on a décidé enfin au
départ tu sais pas comment tu appelé à
résister il y avait polyester qu'il y
avait une autre dame et ultraviolets
pourquoi vous avez choisi le violet avec
warhol je trouvais que c'était beaucoup
plus futuristic beaucoup plus original
beaucoup plus féminin plus ultra c'est
mieux que maria sofia
et violet c'était très artistique la
couleur
j'ai toujours été un peu au delà
ultraviolets ça veut dire
au delà de ce pacte mme halimi ça me
correspondait le sait bien à partir de
là tu t'habilles en violet comme ce soir
enfin avec peut-être des tenues un peu
différent sinon c'était beaucoup plus
violent et les choix et violées les
atouts et les lèvres j'avais dans ton
sac un petit un petit morceau de
betteraves donc toujours m'a dit tu l'as
toujours c'est pas ça la non marchandes
c'est vrai que moi j'ai lu un truc dans
ton bouquin qui m'a complètement fasciné
c'est que tu te mettais à la droite de
warhol comme ça sur les photos dans la
légende des photos dans les journaux ton
nom venait avant celui de tout le monde
si j'ai jamais pensé
la factory tu aurais tu dois
effectivement un récit comme sa quasi
quotidiens la factory il ya d'abord le
sexe alors l'homosexualité à tout crin 1
c'est ça pas choquer la petite française
que tu étais
tous les quatre boucles non parce que
c'est d'abord une époque de révolution
aux états unis et je suis parti pour ça
un peu donc c'était tout à fait normal
et à l'époque les homosexuels c'était
parfait car ils vous dérangeait pas il
ne vous en france aux français pas donc
c'est non sans épée j'étais assez naïve
quand même c'est bizarre un mélange il
m'a fallu plusieurs années au moins je
me rends compte qu'il était vraiment
beau sexuelle bizarre non pourtant il
sait n'est pas oui mais enfin pour te
rends compte qu'il était peut-être que
ça aille avait homosexualité sado
masochistes bondage sans arrêt en fin d
année et puis alors départ tout de
formidables sans arrêt dans l'est dans
les labo photo et auquel warhol
participait pas d'ailleurs parce qu'un
jour du si tu le fasses dans ton bouquin
tu sais on dîne qui dit on la vire et de
la partouze parce que vraiment il y
faisait rien quoi non mais les pâtres
par définition sont des voyeurs
c'est l'oeil qu'ils en gagnent leurs
organes et warhol d'ailleurs à berck on
touche ici même le toucher enfin le bras
même où sa jaquette il était saoul qui
se bougent et tout de suite j'ai très
peur des rapports humains je crois est
pensé que c'était une perte de temps
parce que pour ce qu'il voulait faire ce
qui l'intéressait c'était de faire sa
marque soit culture américaine
les rapports ça prend un temps
il y est arrivé il est même de la
zoophilie un moment ils jettent tout sur
un cheval
oui vous présentiez aussi pour le besoin
du film dans les films il fallait un peu
se dépasser il fallait comme il n'est
pas d'histoires quand tout était
improvisé il fallait faire de plus en
plus de plus en plus faux la drogue oui
mais ça dans les années 60 c'était
devenu d'abord
c'est une longue histoire la drogue a
toujours existé toi t'as jamais vu non
moi j'ai eu très très peur de la drogue
a coûté 1 gâteaux au haschich un jour
avec fatalisme avec dali et puis tu sais
tu as fait d'ailleurs complet non mais
tu dis à partir de là moi non j'ai perdu
mon sac j'ai perdu mes clés je me suis
dit c'est pas pourquoi son côté
bourgeois sa personne on a besoin de ces
clips pour vous trichez souffle des
hackers alors au milieu de tout ça ou
warhol quand même du travail parce que
mon mariage est tout ce monde jour et
nuit fait dérailler tout le monde alors
là la boîte de soupe campbell c'est qui
qu'a eu l'idée parce que les grandes
discussions là-dessus pour savoir qu'est
ce qui a évité de cette boîte de soupe
d'état de champaubert de marcel duchamp
un bâtiment où il a pris un porte
bouteille il était déjà en soi rôle sort
du champ centre-droit mais quand même
moins rôle conduisait toujours son pôle
dit paul et demandé à tout le monde qu
est ce que je dois faire dites moi
qu'est ce que je dois pas très
intelligent et alors si la majorité des
gens lui disaient bon les boîtes de
conserve ses skis la foule si trois
personnes nous disait ton portrait il ne
faisait pas il voulait il n'a jamais dit
je voudrais faire un chef-d'oeuvre il
voulait pas la préoccupation des gens ce
que les gens voulaient c'est comme ça
qu'il a réussie qui a été accepté des
dons presque instantanément il a fait
les fameuses fleurs et tu es là quand
ils passent et à monsieur alors ses
fleurs toi 64 et ans devant un tableau
représentant ces fleurs 1000 $ et le
vent comme on en fait pas cadeau avec le
japon oui ils vont aux mille dollars dès
maintenant sa voix millions de dollars
bref tu l'as toujours cette année gêné
je vais le passage du nord tout en
assurant lâche t il n'est pas assuré à
bord trois sont pas le dire alors il
faisait des films les deux sortes de
films en gros quoi il ya les films comme
ça qu'ils s'appellent slip vois
quelqu'un dormir pendant huit heures ou
l'inde vient style building ou via
d'autres simek maurice et comme trash ou
flèche là c'est déjà plus mis en scène
quand même commercial alors il s'est
quand même fait du pognon avec ses films
il s'est fait des fortunes et les
superstars vous étiez payer quoi que
j'étais super star à 20 dollars par jour
rien de rien de rien on m'a dit l'autre
jour je capitaliser sur bois rouge était
la veuve joyeuse jamais gagné
mais il avait le don de nous amuser on
s'amusait n'était pas du tout force est
d'être là et comme on joue et nous mêmes
enfin c'était très intéressant même
selon psychologique trouver un peu
posséder à la sortie quand même parce
que lui son nez non
[Musique]
c'est à dire que lui avait un plan un
plan d'action noirs n'avaient par noël
était là pour pour le pour l'amusement
bon là au moment où lui lui savait ce
qu'il voulait maintenant je ne reproche
pas c'est à croire en moyenne un qui
tombe par la fenêtre et il dit c'est
dommage qu'on n'ait pas une caméra pour
filmer oui enfin si quelqu'un doit
mourir pourquoi ne pas le filmer et
peut-être c'était sa voix enregistrée de
grande objectivité ce que tu penses
comme truman capote que c'était un
sphinx en secret au absolument c'est
vivre une très belle phrase très belle
et alors un jour du crack complètement
c'est la crise
c'est réparé une catharsis et tu passe
comme ça je sais pas combien de temps
dans son lit tu sais où tu veux te
soigner tu veux pas tu dis que tu ne
soignera tout seul
c'était assez poignant quand on quand on
lis ton bouquin et là je crois que c'est
l'exorcisme qui réussit cette fois par
an contrairement aux premiers noms
peut-être un moment tu peux avoir tes
parents tu arrives dans le midi
évidemment quand on sort de la factory
de chez warhol et quand débarque dans
une maison bien bourgeoise bien
française
mais ça fait du bien quand on le lit
aussi c'est que j'y suis allé pour
presque leur dire au revoir je pensais
que j'allais mourir et c'est eux qui
m'ont ressuscité d'y retourner vers la
religion catholique à ce moment là non
non non non non enfin la religion
catholique mais vert
le christianisme enfin on american olean
de religion comme tu sais plus tôt
évangéliques ont rempli les rôles étudie
les écritures
français c'est pour ça qu'on
est alors devenu tu dis
ultraconservateur c'est vrai oui oui je
sais qu est-ce que c'est à dire que je
pense que la lame salvation que le salut
ne peut vraiment être trouvé 4 avait une
espèce de morale famille quand même
temps pour se remettre de tout ça pour
moins 15 ans je dînais je sais pas si je
suis complètement remis qu'est ce que tu
penses je pense que tu suis très très
content de toi
on change pas de tripes toujours dans le
mille voici le compile pas passer ma
base en 66 à la première écoute la
californie adopte son premier vrai
groupe tipi avec california dreamin john
phillips vendre à un million de désir
à
hu
n'est pas
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après
ouaga
à
le prêt
[Applaudissements]
hinault
[Musique]
deux mois plus tard les mamas et les
papas ce fait leur deuxième millions de
disques avec monday monday champagne
limousine ils font la fête à délair avec
les beatles les beurs et des sous
m
oui
[Musique]
à
mais
ma
mais derrière le mythe les quatre rigole
moins hiver 67 mama cass se fait arrêter
à southampton accusée de vol elle mourra
seuls sept ans plus tard michelle
phillips la blonde ce jour-là agressent
à nos fichiers de police elle finira a
fait des illusions défonce dépression
divorce le groupe split en 68 ce come
back des mecs avortée this way délégués
des to the one love
comme
ça
[Musique]
avec
paris
prêt à porter
et puis
quelques étroits
[Musique]
non
or
et
[Musique]
je n'ai compris
elle ne savait
pas
c'étaient les mamans et les papas se
couche et les mamies et les papys au
palace qui lasse pas d'immense est
dément voici les lunettes de la semaine
la femme idéale pour un rockeur c'est
marie lou baker autoreverse ou non dick
rivers notre pote les bee gees c'est le
mardi quand il met le tango à la sauce
tabasco c'est son vice à boris encore
inconnu il y à deux secondes désormais
toute la france se demande qui est
l'inconnue de la semaine n'a pas fait
des tableaux fiston des photos les
romains en expo une urgence espace
émergence photographe du rock du folk du
blues du funk du peintre claude gassian
expo à la loco bon masse tout paris
s'entassent à bercy moi merci je regarde
lunettes autre message personnel smaïn à
deux attachées de presse quand on dit
câlin et qui est pas sympa c'est pas
dans bois c'est l'autre franco au garrot
juan carlos bravo arroyo au tableau
interview pinceaux
alors eduardo arroyo en 1963
j'ai fait une exposition en espagne qui
déplaît au pouvoir franquiste à l'époque
était obligé de choisir l'exil parce que
finalement il y en a certains artistes
étaient acceptés comme ta pièce comme
heroes mais toi tu as été obligé de s'en
aller
[Applaudissements]
oui mais c'était à moi seul de la partie
avant je suis parti à 58 et puis
effectivement après cette exposition qui
est retourné à 63 je pu rien faire en
espagne jusqu'à que je récupérer mon
passeport français toi tu voulais être
écrivain au départ non oui oui en face
des contradictions bosque aussi à
s'exiler pour être créé ainsi qu'un
projet n'a mérité une contradiction très
grande mais enfin je dessinais beaucoup
tian francs et celui dans la peinture
supprime le problème de la langue c'est
être l'ex il quitte à forcer à temps
c'était une manière dans tout cas cet
éloignement de l'espagne et de la langue
d'espagne on m'a fait peut-être devenir
reine quand il fait une peinture un peu
autobiographique un peu politique
militante mais politique ces tableaux
racontent des histoires démolisseurs sur
léman seulement c'est à dire que moi
c'est tout le monde à part on a parlé
facilement de peinture politique mais
moi c'est ce pari de quoi ça se mange
tout simplement je vois qu'à voir pas
uniquement une obsession c'est il a des
gens qui sont obsédés par les flots par
les champignons l'autre par la
commission par le co produit et moi
c'était l'espagne et qui effectivement
aujourd'hui ça semble un peu rhétorique
par les seconds savais que j'allais
roulement l'espagne est devenue un pays
comme les autres alors donc aujourd'hui
tout un peu difficile de les imaginer qu
est ce que c'était c'est ce qu'on
appelle la figuration narrative
j'accepte cette étiquette c'est à dire
que j'accepte pas ce que vont se tait
venu
non et la critique en général dont des
noms à des mouvements ou à des
générations peut-être c'est plus facile
aussi pour se comprendre mais enfin moi
je veux le construire un peintre très
indépendant toujours j'ai par contre je
dirais que j'ai à partir des générations
de peintres qui ont lutté au
depuis des années 60 contre la station
qui des réactions lyrique comme il est
un truc contre du chant c'était très
fort très scandaleux et à l'époque c'est
vrai que des gens comme jean françois
revel ou au mondial ont protesté quand
tu avais fait avec les calques et y
aille ou une wii et une série de huit
tableaux qui s'appelait la fin tragique
de marcel duchamp c'est à dire que ça
produit en un grand tollé c'était la
dernière manifester qui a signé vrai ton
et ses amis avant de mourir c'était il a
eu de manifester aujourd'hui c'est une
règle compréhensible aujourd'hui c'est
compréhensible qu'un groupe de pain pour
de
manifeste malgré votre appel aujourd'hui
on peut pas imaginer et pourquoi tu es
anti dali parce que thalys étaient assez
figuratif quand même nom tristement de
sela faut le dire tout de suite c'est
vrai que c'est pas très élégant de
parler des morts et ça c'est tout ce
qu'elle a dit qu'il était vivante oui
c'est ça voilà justement mais enfin l'ue
s'étaient prononcés c'était ce terrien
tesero tout simplement comme un conte le
pen parce qu'il est et monarchistes
aussi amenant bayrou c'est pas parce
qu'ils étaient dans un si c'était parce
que quelqu'un qui avait quand même dit
devant le pente de franco a tué 5
jeunes gens en 1975 il a dit il faut les
tuer tous comme des rats et il n'arrive
même pas un mot de pitié le guettait
quand même un catholique
fervent pour des gens qu'au fond ils
étaient des jeunes de jeunes gens qui
étaient quand même
par terre trop des balles tu penses quoi
de l'espagne actuelle je dirais que le
retour des bourbons
pays démocratique tu pensais que ça
allait se passer comme ça du tout parce
que moi ça couve toujours je me suis
trompé ce à quoi j'ai pensé la politique
se séparer ce que je pensais oui non
j'ai su que je pense que nous sommes un
pays comme les autres je répète c'est
quelque chose qui était censée lutter
contre cette idée d d d espagne est
différente nous vivons une situation qui
me convient tout à fait je pense que
enfin je peux
que
curieusement si vous voulez des gens
comme moi qui sont des gens
traditionnellement des gauches sont très
très content de la réelle arrabal aussi
centre de carrier aussi oui c'est ça il
avait deux gérants ils ont les jambes
patients qui sont gré qui soutiennent
par exemple
le travail de droit qui me semble très
très intelligente et très très bien tu
serais qui s'était paris où tout doit
être quel peintre
les gars ça je vous prends des mélanges
de peut-être quilico picabia
c'est un peu de terrain et et aussi
quelques gouttes des légers mais qu'en
même temps pour faire un tableau ça
dépend ça peut venir dans quatre ou cinq
jours ça peut durer un mois ça dépend de
l'élan jeu
ça vaut combien ça vaut couper et
parlons aujourd'hui
et compte parler argent mes concerts
combien bon patron de 600 mille francs à
mais francs
tu viens bouquins chez plon la
collection carnets qui s'appelle
sardines à l'huile à vous et moi
maintenant c'est la moindre des choses
contre quoi bon ma vie ma vie mes
passions mais
les honneurs 6-2 y avoir une définition
de poids d'un dictionnaire
arroyo deux mois
c'est pas
moi je dirais que
passion surtout patient tu as dit être
peintre c'est le 2 murray pourrait
absolument oui oui il faut pas rester
parce que être peintes 7 quelque chose
de
de concret mais c'est pas une blague un
truc enfin
il faut pas non plus penser à
à cette l'idée de la peinture comme des
aspirations pour dénoncer l'idée de que
tu veux peindre et pu voir le demeurer
jusqu'à la fin et que le grand jeu ces
savoirs coin pour moi
si je suis capable encore un tableau ton
avis
si tu avais déjà l'intérêt mais l'idée
c'est ça l'idée c'est est ce que je suis
capable encore de faire un tableau
aujourd'hui tu es un homme serein après
je suis un homme complètement tranquille
et surtout plus tôt je dirais classique
et même des gens même qui m'aiment
beaucoup il parle même
vis-à-vis avec un lien vers un
réactionnaire imsa avant
à oui ça qui est formidable
viva españa yes indeed chine 10 le
courant alternatif passe dans lunettes
scoop bergère s'infiltre au studio
davout pour les quarts ayos rôle de
caballero quand un garçon boucher un
chihuahua un parent avait la main à nos
negra sont dans la même case bac s
qu'ils font du plouc au billie piper cno
rock on dit qu'ils sont les pokes
français non l'époque ce sont les
caillots sanguins
[Musique]
l'homo album et qataris chipie rooney
macquart n'y avoir pas mal quand calame
ares 1 x mini casino
à
[Musique]
quèsaco
nous sommes deux soeurs jumelles nées
sur le signe des gémeaux pas
là
pour trouver les plus arby's des indies
faux s'expatrier à ronchin lire lille ou
bergère à dénicher d'ibm coeur
[Musique]
tonton
je
et
paul
pour vous
en effet
2 sauf sur l'a5 ils ont aussi acheminé
vers son fiston et chez ardisson jérôme
py gens et ces deux pigeons qui font du
jean pipeau gibus chorus
[Musique]
manèges sans feu
le camp seul
bon plus à rien
je regarde
bardou
je devais le 2 août
t
non
nina hagen
didier barbelivien
clémentine célarié là on appelle
les douars d'eau arroyo ysabelle
dufresne il était dans l'une est fan de
l'histoire pour ce soir à bientôt sur
larbi chaussalet bande de nazes
[Musique]
we want
m
bah
mais
voilà moi
wade
[Musique]
et toi
roy
[Musique]
wade
m
[Musique]
toi
oui
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux